maybe we should have saved a peanut
butter for last I don't know what I'm
doing
hey GQ I'm Adam Devine and these are my
essentials
[Music]
I always like to have a hat nearby in
case I wake up and my hair's looking
foul these are like in no exact order
but I usually like to have a hat that
means something to me these are my
Clippers
what's up qui welcome to LA you know
Nebraska that's where I'm from this hat
was given to me by future President Joe
Biden am i casting a vote already no
we'll see we'll see how he does in the
primaries and he gave it to me when I
visited the White House and he was super
cool to me and this hat I feel like
every guy has I have a hat that they
workout in and this was from the movie I
did game over man Brand X stunts which
are the cool stunt team and I like to I
like to get all sweaty in it the hair
girls over there just going to I'm a
rebel now I don't know about you guys
but I have to have shoes and my favorite
type of shoes are vans
they're mad comfy and I like to feel
like I might do a kickflip I've never
done one but I like to feel like if a
skateboarder is available I might
attempt it I wore these shoes on my
stand-up special streaming now live on
Netflix Adam Devine's best time of our
lives these shoes were gifted to me
recently and I haven't worn them yet but
I have like like probably like 50 pairs
of hands and I I like to wear plus
they're cheap baby save a dollar
[Music]
protein is important let's admit that
okay if you want to keep your chassis
tight and you want to build the perfect
meat mountain you have to protein load
and that's why I like peanut butter a
lot of people are like oh that's too
fatty if you eat too much that you get
fat
you'd be the judge not me I don't like
to lie in iron what they put in that
peanut butter I don't like to iron every
time I have iron to anything it ends up
being more wrinkled so that's why I like
Downey's wrinkle release and this
stuff's incredible you just on your
clothes give a little shrink shrink
shrink shrink and it is D wrinkled so
pick up some of this I travel a lot and
I always keep this in my bag you gotta
have your toiletries gang this is my
toiletry bag it's pretty cool it has my
initials in there I'll never tell you
what P stands for Patrick I did I keep a
ton of stuff in here there's myrrh and
shaved stuff a lot of people are like
whoa dude you're 35 years old how do you
look so boyish the answer is I'm wish
your eyes you have to or else you just
look like a old handbag or something and
then I you know you got to stay
deodorize I keep a comb to keep the
locks and all the right places this is a
this is sunscreen I feel like that's
important to you don't to have those
weird age spots when you're an old
person and there's just like a dark spot
right here that's turning purple and
then I also have a little wrinkle
release to go bottle because I'm never
far from a wrinkled shirt and these are
my tour trees gang you guys are these I
bet you do
keeps everything nice and tidy I was
gifted this book the creative block
sometimes when I'm writing I am just
sitting at my desk and the ideas aren't
flowing it's actually really cool you
open it up and there's a bunch of just
writing exercises or just something to
to get the creative juices snail in hey
your neighbor get their story so then
you weirdly are talking to our neighbors
and like in Hollywood like people don't
talk to each other so like Oh what was
this weirdo talking to me I remember him
from a Taco Bell commercial or something
I've done a few of those it's actually
really cool it helps me think of things
that I normally wouldn't think to write
about like spark words clean up your
room it helps me think about like maybe
household chores that I don't like to do
and maybe I can write about that
something that I normally wouldn't want
to write about or think that that might
be boring and then you find creative
outlets to sort of explore create a blog
I don't know about you guys but I like
to keep clean drawers I always keep a
clean batch in my travel bag that way if
I'm ever on the road and I might forget
underwear I always have at least three
pairs Calvin Klein is probably my
favorite underwear Mark Wahlberg has
taught me that this is the sexiest pair
of underwear to own it keeps all the the
nuggets packed in nice and tight I carry
this mostly for this photo because this
is my Fitz bow right here I'm trying to
look like underwear model number three
as a tight package right there someday I
would take off my pants and drop them to
my knees and take off my shirt and flex
for you guys but I've got a lot of
shaking heads no over there
so we'll keep them on for now I feel
that a good watch is definitely an
essential come on guys
clasp up your game so I like love
watches I always have one on whenever
I'm not shooting something because as a
person I like to be able to tell time I
just love watches I think it's so cool
that like the back of this one right
here you could see all the inner
workings on the back and I think that's
pretty awesome all these little pieces
working together I always try to pick up
a watch what I want to remember
something in my life and this watch
right here was my first like nice watch
that I bought five or six years ago now
it's an Omega Speedmaster the Apollo I
want to say the 30th anniversary or 35th
anniversary it is a meteorite face which
is pretty cool I was on the road doing
stand-up and I found out that my house
was broken into and they stole a bunch
of my stuff kind of bummed about that
and I wanted this watch forever and I
walked past and Omega boutique and saw
it in the in the window I swooped this
baby up and I'm I'm glad I have it I
don't have any Rolexes because I think
they're like I mean I think they're
super cool but it's also they're a
little bougie I like Omega is a lot more
they feel like more of like a
workingman's nice watch unless Rolex
wants to send me one in which case I'll
take the Batman with the Jubilee
bracelet thank you sometimes throughout
the day I get a little sluggish so I
like to have what I call my good good
juice I'll crack open a sugar-free Red
Bull and Alec Oi and mix them together
over some ice and that'll jumpstart the
rest of the day I feel like Red Bull is
a little to gasoline II for me so I like
to cut it with a little sparkling water
am i a boozy bad boy you bet your ass
when I was shooting workaholics maybe
like two seasons and we were doing
everything on the show right in it and
acting in it and producing it and so the
days were like 14 15 hour days I needed
something to pick me up throughout the
day and I didn't want to be a drug
addict so I got taught this instead I
would say successful pivot so I noticed
like a bunch of guys when they do these
videos they like we're cool guy leather
jackets people want to hit me when I
wear a leather jacket I've noticed like
I have a very punchable face and I think
when I wear a leather jacket they're
like oh this guy thinks he's all tough I
don't okay do not try to punch me I will
fall and cry
so I like a nice denim jacket I feel
like Levi's specifically just fits me
really nicely like sometimes you get
like these really fashion-forward brands
and you go to put on the denim jacket
and you're like you can't move your arms
I'm a beefy boy I like to say I'm a
light guy living in an app guy world and
this denim jacket fits these lats movie
perfect I speak other languages I have
my ear pods I love them not because I
necessarily like love music I do love
music I'm not a psychopath but I also
like to put them in and be like I'm
sorry I can't I am on the actually talk
right now
so that's why I like my air pod so much
you guys know where to buy these this is
an essential for me I travel all the
time I'm all over the place -
instantiation I'm doing so I like to
have something that I could carry on and
something that some super compact so I
like this away suitcase that I have it's
not pink it is orange I did something
for the NBA Awards and they gave me this
as a gift which is super cool and it is
supposed to be a basketball it's in a
way brand which I didn't know was like a
brand for a while I thought it was like
a play on like home team away team
until my girlfriend's like no that's not
like a very popular suitcase luggage
brand you can charge your phone on it
which TSA all they love that they love
them and they never ask you to take the
battery out pick one out they're pretty
cool he shoots he scores thank you so
much GQ for having me it's been fun
I'm Adam Devine and these are my
essentials
[Music]